ELIZABETH GREEN: Thank
you all for coming.
I'm Dr. Elizabeth Greene, and
I am an Assistant Professor.
I've been about four years
almost out of my Ph.D.
I'm Assistant Professor at
Western University, formerly
called the University
of Western Ontario,
if anyone's heard of that.
We rebranded to
Western University,
like a good company,
any good company
should-- rebrand here and there.
I'm an Assistant Professor
in the Classics Department.
So you probably, maybe
have not had too many arts
and humanities
coming along here.
But one of my favorite
things about what I do,
which I'm an archaeologist,
I'm a Roman archaeologist,
and one of my favorite
things is that it's
very, very collaborative.
So though I'm in a very,
very traditional department
of classical studies
at a university
and that's what I
do during the year,
during the-- definitely don't
do that-- during the summer
I spend in Northern England
up on a site called Vindolanda
on Hadrian's Wall.
Let's hope that--
yay, it's working.
And, in fact, I should
point out my colleague
that I work with is
here with me today as
well in the back,
Alexander Meier.
And we have been working on this
excavation since about 2002.
We have slotted
into a project that
has been going on for
a very, very long time.
The site is called Vindolanda.
It's a Roman fort up
on Hadrian's Wall.
And right now the site is--
or has been for about 45 years
and even longer has
it had excavation,
but it's been run,
directed under the heritage
management of the site.
It's been under the site
of this Vindolanda Trust.
This really amazing
group of people
of scholars and
archaeologists who have taken
care that this site not
only is open for people
to come and visit
and look at, but also
for people to have an excavation
experience of their own.
So for several
decades now people
have been coming to the site,
taking part in excavations
and getting a little piece
of archaeology themselves.
So the director of that
program is Dr. Andrew Birley.
He's the Director of
Excavations on the site.
And then there's a
whole slew of people
who have been taking
care of the site,
and making it available to so
many people in so many ways.
I started there with my
colleague Alex in the back,
in 2002.
And I've been there ever since.
In the summers,
through my Ph.D.,
and then now that
I'm a professor,
I'm bringing my
own students there.
So it's been a site
that has really
been something amazing
for a lot of people.
Like I was saying though,
one of my favorite things
about being an
archaeologist is that I
collaborate with tons of people.
So we're running everything
from arts and humanities, which
is where I came from,
in fact, with a degree
in classical studies.
Just really super interested
when I was 18 in the Romans.
Wanted to learn more about the
Romans and the Greeks, and then
somehow made it all
the way to archaeology.
But what I'm doing
consistently is collaborating
with scientists,
and tech people,
and all sorts of
individuals in the field.
And this is really one
of my favorite things
about being an archaeologist.
Now, do we have any sort
of secret classic majors
or archaeology majors or
anthro majors in the room?
Not a-- oh, we do.
AUDIENCE: History.
ELIZABETH GREENE: History, OK.
Fantastic.
What did you guys do?
AUDIENCE: I was a classic major.
ELIZABETH GREENE: You
were a classic major?
High five.
Right on.
That's fantastic.
So was I. So I came
through it really
through the cultural
world, and just
interested in these people.
And then came all the
way to archaeology.
So now my world is opened up
to all these different people.
OK, so for the people who
aren't classic majors in here,
let me just tell you a little
bit about the site, and about
Roman Britain.
And then for where
we're talking about,
I'll give you some context.
The map that you're
looking at is, indeed,
a map of the Roman Empire.
And this is one of
the first things that
got me thoroughly interested
was wow, that's huge.
The Roman Empire now
covers 42 modern countries.
So this is really amazing,
as far as I was concerned.
When you look at it now, where
you see our work taking place
is all the way up
on-- and I'll just
use this because I can't
point at all the screens-- all
the way up here, literally
on the Northwest.
The furthest Northwest
corner of this Roman Empire
that you could possibly be.
So really, really far
from the center of Rome.
And you can imagine
with that comes
all sorts of interesting
things, like what
is it like to live
on a frontier?
What is it like to live
in a conquered zone?
There's all sorts of
questions we could ask.
What I'm going to
tell you about today
though is a little
bit of how we come
to some of those questions.
How we discover some
of those questions.
So there we all the way up
in that Northwest corner.
The site is really famous
for a couple of things.
It has some really
unique preservation
called anaerobic preservation.
You guys probably all
know what that is.
It doesn't have any
oxygen in the soil.
Therefore, we have finds
that we don't really
get in most archaeological
environments--
organic finds-- leather,
wood, things like that.
The site actually
has-- this is something
that's close to my heart.
It has over 4,000
Roman leather shoes.
And people ask me
all the time, why?
Is this a shoe production site?
No, not at all.
It's just because we have
this anaerobic preservation.
But you might not
have ever thought
we'd have shoes from
the Roman world.
We do, indeed.
But this site has
absolutely the largest.
That's one thing it's
very well-known for.
Has anybody ever been up
here to Hadrian's Wall,
or been to Vindolanda?
All right.
Fantastic.
Good.
So we have some people.
If you go there now, the first
thing you see in the museum
is you stare at a wall of shoes.
It's really quite amazing.
And they're nearly
2,000 years old.
The other thing the site is
very famous for are these things
called the Vindolanda
writing tablets.
Ink on wood.
Direct messages--
letters, personal letters,
duty rosters from the Roman
Army who inhabited this site.
What else?
There's personals or postcard.
What you're looking
at here is probably
the earliest female
handwriting from Europe.
There's a little private
message in this letter.
Most of it is a scribe.
Right here.
This little private
message right there.
It's a letter between
two wives, and one wife
says to the other,
two military wives--
they're wives of the commanders.
And one wife says,
"Oh, please, please,
come to my birthday party.
This day would be so much
better if you were here."
Really kind of amazing.
Nearly 2,000 years
later you're think, oh.
The first letter
they actually found
said, "I'm sending you
socks and underwear."
So you can imagine everything
from socks and underwear
to telling us exactly what these
individuals are doing on site.
So this is another category
why this site is very famous.
There's all sorts of really
unique and interesting things
there.
Everybody should go visit
when you get to England.
But what I want to do today,
rather than just take you
through some cool finds
from the site where I work,
is to tell you about an
archaeological trench.
And what happens to an
archaeological trench,
from beginning to end.
And how we are
collaborating with all
these different people.
Because in the end, we're
looking for very small things,
but it has to start
much, much, much bigger.
Has anybody been on an
archaeological excavation?
Other than [INAUDIBLE]?
Excellent.
Three people.
That's really cool.
So I want to talk to you about
that life cycle of the trench.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: I would
expect at least
to be able to identify
the words here,
but it looks like there's
no vowels or something?
ELIZABETH GREENE: Right, right.
There are vowels.
What you're looking
at is Latin cursive.
So it is an early--
have you ever
seen a medieval manuscript?
This is a very, very early
script from the Romans,
from-- when did they
start using this?
Probably-- when's
our earliest, Alex,
for cursive, Latin cursive?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
didn't print
in block capitals like
on an inscription.
ELIZABETH GREENE: Yes.
So on an inscription--
yeah, who's been in a museum
and seen an inscription?
Lots of you, right.
And you see these nice block
capitals, and, in fact,
we recognize that from
kindergarten as well.
They're writing these
nice block capitals.
This is something totally
different, but it is, in fact,
Latin.
But it's an interesting story
when they first found these.
The excavator, Robin Birley
who directed the site
for a very, very long time.
He looked at it and thought
is this a different language?
What am I looking at?
But, in fact, when you start
looking at, it's Latin cursive.
We have other media
that have this.
A lot of large,
large kiln sites,
you'll see orders written out
on ceramics in this cursive.
So we have a lot of
cursive-- Papyri,
we get Latin cursive as well.
It is just difficult to
read, but once you understand
what it looks like,
it's just Latin.
Cool, huh?
So I want to start
you understanding
how going through this site,
and how we start an excavation,
and what we go through,
and then where we end up.
How do we get this data?
What kinds of questions
are we asking?
So we start-- one
of the other things
I love about Roman archaeology
or just archaeology in general
is that really it's big data
put together with small data.
We're looking to
answer big questions,
but we have to
put together a lot
of small stuff, a lot
of little bitty stuff.
What you're looking at
here on Google Earth,
obviously, is an image of
the landscape very, very
close to Vindolanda.
It's just North of the site.
The site is very close
to Hadrian's Wall.
So what do you can see here are
a couple of different things.
I think that the things
that are so prominent to me
are this right here.
You've got something
right here, and you've
got something-- I think
the most prominent thing is
this right here.
What you can really see is
the late Carboniferous Period.
You can see the Romans.
And then you can see
the 20th century.
So you can see three
different things.
You're looking at what's called
the Whin Sill Crag right here.
And Hadrian's Wall built
right on top of that.
Hadrian's Wall is this
enormous wall, 15 feet high,
89 feet long, that the emperor
Hadrian built in the 120s.
He needed to consolidate.
He wanted the empire to be sort
of closed off a little bit more
than it was.
He wanted to protect
it from non-Roman land.
So he took the opportunity
with this enormous, literally
from the Carboniferous
Period, geological formation
that runs almost across
the whole country,
mostly in the center.
And he built the great big
wall right on top of it.
So you're seeing the
shadow of that right there.
But, in fact, the other thing
that you see in this picture
is something that was
dug by the Romans.
Now, when I ask
my students this,
what do you think
this is, most of them
think it's a rail line,
something like that.
Indeed not.
That is an enormous ditch that
was built, dug by the Romans
in order to protect
Hadrian's Wall,
and in order to protect this
military zone that they created
with Hadrian's Wall.
So when you look
at this, you can
see the only other most
prominent thing is this right
here, which is the
20th century quarry.
And really you can only
see it because it's
filled in with water.
But all through the landscape
you have the Romans.
You have this, you have
Hadrian's Wall here,
you have this giant
ditch called the vallum.
And all of these
little bits down here
are also telling us things
about the Roman Period, in fact.
Those are small marching
camps and little enclosures
and things like that that
actually, most of them
date to the Roman Period.
So we take this big
data and we have
to combine it with these
questions and ask ourselves
how we're going to come
down onto something else,
since they're final answers.
And the other thing
to point out, though,
is that we can't get rid
of some of our old data.
We have much more refined stuff
sometimes, even from the 1970s.
So what you're looking at
here is an aerial photograph
of Vindolanda from somewhere
in the mid '70s when
they had-- there's two
things that work really
well for aerial photography.
That is a drought, one thing.
And a little light dusting
of snow is the other thing.
Because you get nice contrast.
You either get dead
grass during a drought
where you have
things underneath.
Or a light dusting of snow
gives you really great contrast.
So if we go diving into
the Vindolanda archives,
the archives of the
Vindolanda Trust,
we find things like
this, which is really
what I would kind of consider,
though it's showing us
something large,
sort of a small data.
We don't want to forget about
these old pieces of information
that we have.
We want to bring this
all together in order
to decide where it is
that we want to excavate
to answer some of our questions.
So I'll draw your
attention on this.
You're looking at the fort.
So it's that same fort
as the aerial photography
that I showed you
before, the green one.
And you've got this structure
right in the middle here.
That was the only
thing excavated back
then, except for some of the
gates and things like that.
I'll draw your attention
into two different areas,
and that is this right here
to the West of the fort.
And then this area to
the sort of Northwest.
We call that the North
field, and that's actually
where I'm going to be
concentrating today to show you
what we've been doing recently
on the excavations there,
and how we're answering
some of our questions.
If you look at Vindolanda
today, what you see
is that extramural
settlement right there.
That is, in fact, that first
square just to the West
that I showed you.
So I've shifted you again.
We're facing a
different direction.
We're sort of looking
Northeast now.
But when you look at
all of those lumps
and bumps in that last image
there, and you say to yourself,
gee, we may have
something in there.
There might be something
underneath the ground there.
You then do an excavation, and
that is, indeed, what you find.
You have buildings,
and those buildings
are populated with
all sorts of artifacts
that are going to tell
us a lot about what's
happening on this
archaeological site.
If you walk around
the site today,
this is what it looks like now.
This is the site
that you will see.
And by the way, it's
a fantastic visit,
if you're in Northern England.
A great place to go.
So I'll draw your attention
back to that field right there.
We also identified in some
of these older pictures,
and then combining it with
things like Google Earth,
we've identified
that there might
be something happening
over there as well.
We've got this large
line going across here.
And in other photographs
we see a nice little corner
right there that we thought
might be the corner of a fort.
OK, so what do we do next?
Nowadays, we will do
some geophysical survey.
Has anybody in the room
ever seen "Time Team?"
Yeah.
Good.
So a couple of people.
The reason I ask
is because nobody
used to know what
geophysical survey is.
You guys have
probably heard of it
in science classes
and things like this.
But nobody used to know.
But now that "Time
Team" is out there
and everybody can watch
shows about archaeology,
we have the tourists
that come up to the edge,
and they're very, very educated,
and they say, excuse me,
have you done your geophysical
survey on this area yet?
And, of course,
yes, indeed we have.
But it's really great
that people actually--
sort of regular
people on the street
are understanding a lot
of this more often now.
We do geophysical
survey of some sort.
What we have done on the site is
called the magnetometer survey.
You could also do resistivity,
you could do ground
penetrating radar, which
all measure different things
in the subsoil.
What the magnetometer
survey's doing
is measuring the magnetic field.
It's basically giving you
anomalies, positive and
negative anomalies, based
on the magnetic field below.
So it's not exactly
like 3D vision,
but it's telling us
what's down there.
It sometimes works very well.
It sometimes doesn't
work very well.
You're looking at a
grayscale plot, which
doesn't do very much
for us right now.
What that needs to do is
be rendered and interpreted
into something more.
So what you have is
negative anomalies--
all of these little
gray bits here.
These are negative anomalies.
And those are usually stone
buildings, things like this.
And by the way, I
should point out
that this isn't something--
we don't pull out
our own magnetometer survey.
This is one of those
collaborations.
We have a team come
in, do the survey.
We use right here TimeScape
archaeological surveys
in Northern England.
They do the survey,
they put this together.
So this is one of
those instances where
I get to talk to all sorts
of interesting people
and walk along the
field with them
and talk to them about
what they're doing.
And then they send me
this material back.
We also have positive anomalies,
just to get back to this.
Those are those dark ones there.
Some positive,
though, rather vague,
which are these
sort of dotted ones.
And what I'll draw
your attention
to is this right here, and some
of these very, very strong--
they're called
bipolar, or they're
very magnetic
reactions that we get.
And this is, in
fact, something we
were interested in right here.
And you can even really see
that well on the grayscale plot
as well.
So what we've got
here is an idea
of what is underneath
the ground.
We want to know if we're
looking at potentially ditches,
if we're looking
at stone buildings.
It's worth pointing out, though,
that this does not always work,
because I have, myself,
excavated several stone
buildings in that field
that didn't turn up
on any of these plots.
Now, ours is about 10
years old at this point.
And this summer we're
going to do more GPR
or more geophysics of some sort.
And this is the sort of thing
that is changing all the time
and becoming better
and better and better.
So we will do more
of this later.
I will also say,
though, so like I said,
we can't forget about
the old techniques.
We also will marry this
and get more information.
We'll put all of this together
to get information off
of a classic earthwork survey.
So this is in 2010, I
believe this one was done,
and that will be done
it with a total station.
So they're out there, they're
surveying-- proper survey.
You guys have seen
the road work crews.
They were out there with
total stations and such.
But I should say that this
is the same exact thing that
could have been done 50
years ago with a dumpy level,
and it's almost the
same exact thing.
It wouldn't have been as
precise, by any means.
It's almost the same exact
thing that William Roy
could have been out
there 200 years ago.
He's the guy that started up
the idea of the Ordnance Survey
in England with a
theodolite-- that long ago.
And it's worth noting that the
Romans were doing very, very
similar things with
a groma, a tool
called the groma where
they just-- that's
how they got those
straight lines
and those straight ditches.
And they knew how
to survey as well.
So really, really interesting.
But we have to remember
that these things, this kind
of information is giving
us really great data as
well, because it's
telling us what's
happening on the surface.
Which could very
much have everything
to do with what's
happening down below.
So kind of return yourself
to your fourth grade learning
how to read like a topo map.
These are telling us that this
is a very-- these little arrow
things are telling us that
there's a very steep hill right
here.
And what we came up with was
this really nice corner here
that looks like something
we're quite interested in.
Back in 2010 we had dropped
a trench right here,
and you can just see
the outline of it.
And we got the very, very
corner of this red feature.
These are fort ditches.
They're defensive ditches.
And we realized that if we have
defensive ditches out here,
then we probably also
have a fort out there.
So what we're looking
at is potentially
some of the earliest buildings
on site, some of the earliest
occupation on this
site, which might really
change the way we
see the frontiers.
Like you're kind
of wondering well,
what's the big picture here?
What are we looking for?
This might change
the way we actually
view the frontier at
this point in time,
because if we have occupation
here 10 or 15 years earlier,
that might really make
a difference in how
we see the occupation
by the Romans
and the consolidation
of this frontier.
So we use our classic
earthwork survey as well.
Now, I threw this in here
because a lot of people ask us,
why do we not use
metal detectors?
Why are we not just out
there with metal detectors?
And there's a couple
of reasons why
we don't use metal detectors.
One, this is a UNESCO
World Heritage site.
It is a scheduled, or I
should say scheduled monument
in England.
And on sites like this, you
cannot have metal detectors.
They're not allowed.
They're illegal on site.
Now, we could probably
put in a permit,
we could ask for a permit
from English Heritage who's
the overseeing government,
overseeing body,
and we could use the metal
detector if we wanted.
But what we like to
do with-- we want
to put out a vision
to the public
that metal detectors are
not necessary for us.
And one of those reasons is
that when people go out there
with metal detectors
and they just do this
and then they find
something and they dig down,
they pull something right out
of its archaeological context.
Whether you go down a foot
or you go down three feet,
you pull it right out,
and we have no information
about what's behind this,
around, underneath, above.
Nothing about the context,
the stratigraphic unit,
I should say, of this artifact.
So that's a very big problem.
But also, it is
prioritizing metal.
Before we looked at some really
interesting leather shoes.
They were telling
us about the kinds
of people that are
living here on site.
We looked at wooden
writing tablets.
They're telling us a lot of
information about what they're
doing on site, who they are,
what they're thinking about,
what they're working on.
None of those will be found
with a metal detector.
So we really have to remember
that archaeology is bringing
lots of information
together, none
of which can be done with just
sort of one piece of equipment.
And metal detectors really
just don't do anything for us
in that sense.
So a lot of people
ask me that, so I
wanted to put in a little bit.
So all right, how
do we pick our spot?
We're going to go
in there, we're
going to excavate,
what do we do now?
I ask you to look at that area
right there on the magnetometer
survey.
And, in fact, that is where
we decided to start digging,
because we had questions.
There was a potential that this
might be a kiln, because this
is one of those bipolar,
one of those intensely
magnetic, as you can
see in the key there,
one of those intensely
magnetic anomalies.
And those are often
associated with kilns,
with a very high ferrous--
of burnt material that you
find around kilns.
So we decided to go
right into that spot,
and as you can see there,
we started the trench.
We peeled away the ground
surface, the plow zone we often
call it, because this
area has been affected
by agricultural working
for hundreds of years.
That was the trend in 2012.
And we also dropped a trench
very nearby in 2013 and '14.
We get in there pretty quickly,
peel off all of that top level,
and what are we looking for?
Basically, archaeology, when
you are just starting out,
you're looking for
changes in the soil.
And some of you might
be able to make out
that right through here, we
have a sort of dark curve right
in through here.
We have a dark kind of splat we
can call it maybe right here.
We have a slightly
lighter area right here.
And then also just
over a here we
have something
that's bright orange.
I'll draw your
attention to that.
And in case you can't see any
of that, I've circled it for you
and made squares.
Now one of the other problems
with the magnetometer survey,
and again, how I'm
saying that we really
have to bring together
different techniques.
We can't just use
sort of our science
and say, OK, let's just
peek under the ground
and we'll see what's there.
Because that's not telling
us the whole story.
And in fact, it's
not even really
telling us 50% of the story.
Because what is giving
us our readings?
And we have no idea if those
readings are from the Roman
Period, or I could
go all the way back
to the Bronze Age
for that matter,
whether they're from the Iron
Age, or the Roman Period,
or the Medieval Period,
or the Victorian Period,
or for that matter,
50 years ago.
And indeed, this little--
actually quite large
and quite an annoyance
inside of my trench-- this
is a very, very large
Victorian drain.
So this field was used
in the 19th century
for grazing animals.
Very wet, very mucky.
And they did all sort of things
to attempt to drain that field.
And that is, indeed,
with that is.
That is a drain that I
will record, of course,
and take a look at.
But we kind of want to go
through pretty quickly.
It was very much in the way.
It's still running, in fact.
Still works quite well.
This over here turned out to
be a pit, a Roman Period pit.
So you can have things
of different time periods
right next to each other.
This is also a Roman Period pit.
But I'll draw your attention
into this red square right
here, and that orange little
kind of rectilinear feature
right there.
Hopefully it's coming
up on the screen.
In the interest
of time, I'm just
going to show you
exactly what that was.
Boom.
That was a kiln.
So once we excavated
from top down to bottom,
we do this what we
call stratographically.
We dig down in
stratigraphic units,
recording each one
as we go, so we
understand how the
archaeological site was built
up, and then, therefore,
how we're essentially
pulling it down.
Because archaeology
ultimately is destructive.
We have to record
it in such a way
because we're not
going to get it back,
once we excavate everything.
So you're looking at what
turned out to be a kiln.
Now, one thing I'll point out
is that the very first inkling
of this kiln being here
was just that over there.
That is that little
orange rectilinear area.
And what we end up with,
once we excavate everything
from 2012-- well, actually,
this is the 2013, '14 trench.
After two years we end up with
this enormous kiln foundation
right here, and a
secondary kiln over here.
So this is a really
large complex
where they were
making brick, tile.
The material that
came out suggested
they're making brick and tile.
But then we found
material suggesting
they're making
quite nicer things.
There was a mold for
maybe a small figurine
type of thing or
something that was maybe
put onto a vessel of some sort.
And we also found pottery,
what we call pottery wasters.
We found the
offshoots, basically,
the remnants of pottery that
misfired or something like that
and they'd just chuck
it off into the ground.
So really interesting
stuff coming out of here.
But this leaves us with
a number of questions.
When we find a
feature like this,
we're wondering a
whole number of things.
One, I'm always going back
to the magnetometer survey
and I'm saying, OK, that really
did not-- that whole thing is
there, but there's no
indication what any of that is.
So just another
reminder that we still
need to always get out
there with our trowels,
with our spades, and excavate
these areas that we thought
looked interesting on
the magnetometer survey.
So some of the
questions that we're
asking once we find
a feature like this
is when was the complex
active, we'd like to know.
We want to know what
was produced here.
We want to know how it
was produced, what kind
of production they're using.
We want to know where these
final products were used.
So one of the big
questions we're always
asking in archaeology what
is the scope of this site?
Do we have this
material moving just
onto the main site
of Vindolanda?
it moving out onto the frontier?
Is it moving out
of Britain, even?
We want to know all
of these things.
And then how much impact
did this site actually
have on its surroundings?
So the first couple
of things are easy,
and you guys have probably all
heard of radiocarbon dating.
We now combine radiocarbon with
accelerated mass spectrometry
dating, as well.
And the great thing about that,
with traditional radiocarbon
dating you need quite a
large sample of carbon,
of some sort of burnt material.
With AMS dating, you really
only need a very small amount,
maybe even one gram I think they
can get some information from.
So that's really useful.
However, there are problems
with any kind of C14.
And that is that we get
these windows with Carbon-14
that could be as
large as mine was.
80 AD to 230 AD.
And, in fact, that
is-- Kate knows--
that is almost the
lifespan of the site.
We know these Roman Periods.
We know that the
place is occupied
well into the fifth
and sixth centuries.
But in terms of sort of
intense Roman activity,
that, right now, we have
started at about 85.
If we can push the
date of the site
back a little bit
or up a little bit,
really, into the '70s,
that would be handy.
But 80 doesn't give me too
much great information,
and then all the way to 230.
And the probabilities go down,
down, down, down, down, down,
down, if you want
to hem that in.
So you can say, well, it
might have dated to about 160,
but that's only with
a 60% probability.
So that's a bit of a
shame with radiocarbon.
That's why we don't
actually use it very much.
Radiocarbon goes
back 50,000 years.
It's good for things
that are 5,000
and 10,000 and more years old.
But when you're in a very
historical period where,
in fact, you have the
potential to find things that
say this stone was carved in
113 AD in the month of October.
It doesn't really help
you out quite as much.
Now, we don't have any
precise dating like that yet.
We don't have any inscriptions
from our little kiln area
out there.
But we will at some point.
So there are a few
problems there.
There's some very cool
stuff, though, going on.
There is this thing
called archeomagnetic
dating that you can do in
something like a kiln that
has been burnt, had been fired
over and over and over and over
again.
And this takes the
magnetic direction
of the soil when
it was last fired.
So it could actually tell us
not when it began to be used,
when it was first used,
but when it was last fired.
You take these
samples of the soil.
You have to mark the
true North on it.
And then you send
it off to a lab--
so again, this is not
something that I personally
walk into the next room
and start looking at.
You send it off to the lab that
works on archeomagnetic dating,
and they could give you a
fairly reasonable time span.
Sometimes, if you're lucky,
same with dendochronological
dating-- do you guys know dendo
where you read the time rings,
or those tree rings rather?
You hope you have a
good sample, and it's
going to tell you
where magnetic,
where the Earth's magnetism
was at the time of last firing.
Now, one problem for England.
We don't actually have
the baseline data yet,
that you need to have
these curves where
you have all the baseline
data and then you plug it in.
So very much like
dendrochronological
dating where you are
plugging your tree ring
sequence into known sequences.
We don't have the data yet
fully for Northern England,
or for England at all.
So they're building it
up, and actually we're
hoping to be a part of that
with this kind of dating.
But the best ones,
the best baseline data
is for the Southwest
in the states,
Southeast in the states, and
actually in the mid-continent.
So all entirely
within the states.
So it's getting there, though,
and that's one of those things,
it was developed, I
think, in about 1992.
Takes a couple of decades
to really get this going.
So we're not quite
there yet for our kiln,
but hopefully we
can be a part of it
and we might be able to
get something off of it.
We might be able to get a
fairly decent date off of that.
So what and where?
The questions that we ask
that are really more, I'd say,
the cultural side
of me is saying,
oh, how are we going to
discover what and where?
What is being produced
there and where is it going?
This is something that
I really want to know.
So how do we analyze ceramics
from kiln production.
We do a couple of
different things.
Throughout the
excavation you find
any number of bits of ceramic.
You're looking here at the mouth
of a large jug of some sort.
You're looking at some
of the body shards,
but then also around
here there are
bits of brick, tile, all sorts.
And what we end up
with, really-- anyone
who's been on an excavation
will remember this-- you end up
with gobs and gobs
and gobs of pottery.
Bag and bags and bags.
And they're all labeled
with the right context,
so you've got all these
different numbers everywhere.
And you then take
all this and you
analyze what the
pottery is made out of.
How many do you have of
this type and that type.
And they all, if you've got
a nice sequence of styles,
then it's going to
tell you a rough date,
a sort of seriated date
for that type of pottery.
But what we can do
here with the kiln,
because what we
really want to know,
we want to create baseline
data with the kiln
to know what is
being produced there.
So we pull out what we know is
called a waster from this kiln.
So like I said before,
you get all of these--
these are basically
factory seconds.
So if you go to a
pottery today, you've
got a shelf that has all this
sort of junkie stuff that
was misfired or something
and you can buy it for $1.
They don't have the shelves.
They just chuck them
off into these pits.
So around a kiln we find
a series of large pits.
They're full of ash, full of the
refuse from ceramic production,
from the kiln.
And then also a whole
bunch of bad pots
and bad tiles, bad bricks.
So what you get are
things that have,
let's say, an uneven
surface-- excuse me,
an uneven surface that would not
have been good for walking on,
for actually using.
Maybe a pot that was
misfired so it wasn't fired
to a high enough temperature,
so it's very friable.
Or something that maybe sunk in.
So you find these,
and we can use these
for-- these are
really nice, too,
because we don't want to
put them in the museum.
So if somebody wants to take
them and cut them up and put
them through mass
spec or do whatever,
then that's quite all right.
So we send these off
and we do something
called ceramic petrography.
It's sometimes also
called ceramic petrology.
Either one.
And we get these thin sections.
Now again, this is
a technique that's
been around for quite a while.
Now, I don't have my thin
sections yet from 2014,
so what you're
actually staring at
is a lunar thin section, just
so that I didn't confuse you
with any earthly stone.
This is from the moon.
Yeah, it's pretty, isn't it?
So what it's doing is once it
gets a very, very-- you get
a very thin section of
the stone or the ceramic
or whatever it is
you're looking at.
It goes onto a slide.
You look at it under
the microscope.
And you can see exactly what is
making up that local geology,
that local clay.
So we also will test
the local ground clay
and see if they're using
that local ground clay.
And then you get
baseline data as to what
your local production
looks like.
And then what we need to do is
convince everybody around us,
convince all these
other sites, OK,
what we'd really like is
for you to give us samples
so that we can understand
if our material's going over
to your site, going
over to Corbridge
or down the road to the
other military forts.
If we can convince a lot of
people, then we can say, great.
Maybe we can see if our material
is going off of the island
or is it going down to London.
Something like this.
So it's really interesting
questions that could be asked.
And we do all this through
sort of simple things
like ceramic petrography.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It seems you
can do a little math,
you'd probably know how many
bricks they produce an hour.
ELIZABETH GREENE: Yes.
Yes.
Actually, in fact,
this afternoon I'm
meeting with a colleague in New
York who does a lot of that.
She's over at the New York--
I think-- New York's-- anyway.
I won't mess that up.
Yes.
So a lot of people do.
You can count the-- you
look at the size of it,
you can figure out how
many fires have occurred.
If it's been
excavated correctly,
so all these pits that
we're talking about.
And then you can figure out
how many have been in there.
Now, there's always a
variable because we're not
going to know exactly how
many times it was fired.
But yeah, you can
do that for sure.
If I were here
tomorrow after her,
I'd probably sound much
more intelligent on that.
So we do this also in
conjunction with other things.
We use mass
spectrometry as well.
Mass spec, I will say,
is way more expensive.
So an archaeological
budget is not huge,
unless you're a site like
Catal Huyuk or something
that has a lot of interest
from other people,
or sort of Herculaneum.
The Villa of the Papyri.
Hewlett Packard
gives tons of money
to the Villa of the Papyri.
That would be fantastic, but
mass spec costs a lot of money.
But if you use your
budget correctly
and you get a few key samples,
because, of course, what
mass spec is doing is giving you
the exact chemical composition.
So that's just going to give you
a little bit more information.
But again, bringing some
of these older techniques
in with the newer ones
is always something
that I really like
about archaeology.
You can't forget about the older
stuff together with the newer.
We also have obligations
to the future.
So we need to record this site,
and what you're looking at here
is a really-- you might be
thinking, wow, paper and pen.
But what we start with
out there in the field
is a piece of paper called
a context sheet that
is going to tell us everything
about the stratigraphic unit
that we just excavated.
Tell us about that soil.
Tell us about that area exactly.
Everything from what
units are around it,
to what the soil
actually looked like.
Was it clay?
Was it full of stone?
We even talk about what kind
of weather was out there.
That top right corner.
And that's because
we want to know
whether the excavator
would have been
able to see the soil correctly.
If it was too wet, if it
was too dry, if the sun--
the most basic things can
throw you off in archaeology
sometimes.
If it's very, very sunny and
hot, the soil just gets baked
and you can't actually
see the soil changes,
and you're really
hoping for rain.
And then you do because
you're in Northern England.
It rains, and you
get too much rain,
and then you've got
water everywhere.
So there are really
basic things that
can throw you off a little bit.
But what we're striving for is
a complete record of the site
so that when somebody looks at
this in 10 or 20 or 50 years,
they can understand exactly
what it was that we did.
So we start with
this context sheet.
We have just rough sketches
of what's happening.
And what's really happening
behind the scenes,
so there's people running
around with various tools.
What you've got here
is a total station,
and that's how we get the plan.
So I'm sure many of you
have seen a total station
or used a total station.
We get the plan of the site.
So we need to leave these
basic records of what
the building looked like,
where exactly it was.
This is going to be tied
in precisely with the site,
with the rest of the site,
with the trig points.
And luckily enough,
since we're in England,
we also know exactly where
we are meters above sea level
because we've got the
Ordnance Survey trig points,
so that's really handy as well.
And we can see one,
actually, right
on top of this hill
that's quite nearby.
So it's very handy to work
in a place like England.
So we build plans.
We have full plans of the site.
We also draw sections.
Now, what's really
cool, though, is
that this stuff is becoming
much, much easier now.
Because we can do things
like just take a photograph
and put it into Illustrator, or
put it into any kind of program
now, and create our site
plans, and create our profiles.
So what you're looking
at here is a record
of exactly what the
profile of the trench
looks like of what we excavated,
what kind of material.
The one that would
go into publication
would have the contact
numbers on there
so we would know
exactly what you have.
You see these little
dashed lines right here.
Those are marking the
breaks in the context.
So this just tells
us exactly where
each one of these
contexts lay and how
we removed it from the site.
So these are the basic
records that we leave.
Lately, we've been coming up
with a lot more interesting
things that we
can do with stuff.
One is this 3D photo
modeling, which
is becoming really,
really handy.
And that's because it leaves
us with a vision of exactly
what these features look like,
exactly what the trench looked
like.
Because one thing that a lot
of people don't think about
is that this trench
is located out
in the middle of
a farmer's field,
and we have to backfill that.
So actually, I think that
it's backfilled right now.
I think that last
week the farmer
came out and backfilled it.
And one thing is that
you can't leave kind
of like a swimming pool.
You can't leave a big
giant hole in the ground.
They don't like that.
It's actually illegal.
It's an English heritage.
It's a rule.
It's a law that you have to
fill these things back in,
unless you're going
to consolidate them.
You can't leave these
large trench edges
if people are going to be
walking through the field.
And as you know in
England, there's
lots of public right
of ways, access.
What do they call
it, right to Rome.
Which is great, fantastic.
But you can't leave these
giant holes in the ground.
So it has to be recorded
to such a degree
that you would be
able to return to it.
So what's been really
great lately with 3D
photo modeling is that we
can take an image of this
exactly as it looked, and we
can manipulate-- it's also
really good for online
journals and things as well.
And we can manipulate it
to be able to see anything,
even looking underneath to see
exactly how much soil we took
out, if we're
interested in that.
I'm not so interested in that.
But it's really just a
fantastic way of seeing
exactly what the details.
Now, what you're looking at here
is really a basic-- this is,
I believe we used
Agisoft to start with.
This is actually a
pretty basic-- sorry,
let me come out again--
a pretty basic program.
We haven't done our sort of
full scale program yet on here.
But you can see how
useful this really
is to be able to get a
vision of exactly how we
left this feature.
So we take a million
still photographs as well.
But if we ever wanted
to return to it
and say, right, how
did we leave that,
we have that right
here in front of us.
It's also very handy
for the entire trench.
So at the end now,
what we do is have
this guy called-- he's
from the Aerial-Cam
I think his company is called.
And he comes along in
the middle of the season
and at the end of
every season and he
photographs the entire site.
All of our trenches,
everything that we've done,
and he will do now 3D
models for us as well.
So we can see-- this doesn't
look like much right here,
but this is one of these
very important ditches that's
going to date
possibly-- we think
it dates to an earlier period.
And we're hoping that the
evidence that comes out of here
will push the site
back a little bit
and be a part of
an earlier frontier
that we didn't know we
were a part of before.
So that would be
really fantastic.
But if there's any
question later on,
if we're saying to ourselves,
OK, how did we leave that?
What did that look like?
Because you think on August
5 when you leave the site
you're going to
remember everything,
but of course you don't.
And so we have these fantastic
records of it right now.
And this is all
really just getting
better and better and better.
We're not going to be out
there with a total station
at some point.
We're just going to
be out there with GPS
and we need it to be to the
centimeter is the issue.
But these things are changing
and becoming far more
interesting over the
next couple of years,
over the next couple of decades.
I can't even imagine where
we're going to be in 20 years.
So it's really fantastic.
Also, what's really handy
for us is these quadcopters.
I kind of want to
call it a drone,
but I'm not going to call it
a drone, little quadcopter.
These can cruise around,
so archaeologists
are using this to really be
able to get up above the site.
Now, the other thing though,
it's not that terrible
if you've got a nice angled
photograph, because these days
we can just use angle
recognition software.
Now, of course, the
problem with archaeology
is always affording this.
But you can get a
angled image and then
you can always just rectify it
and be looking straight down.
But you can also go
out there and get
a quadcopter and a GoPro, and
you can go right over your site
and you get beautiful
aerial shots of everything
that you've just excavated.
Really great PR pictures
as well for marketing.
And what you get, when
you're down on the ground,
you really sometimes can't see
the forest through the trees.
It's really difficult
down there to actually see
what's going on.
When you hover up
above it, and this
is actually not
from the quadcopter.
This picture that
you're looking at
is just simply
from a 40 foot pole
that our guy Adam Stanford
of Aerial-Cam uses.
Goes up, takes the shot, and
this is what it looks like.
But you really just get this
much, much greater sense
of what the whole
site looks like,
of the rectilinear structures,
of exactly what's going on
in this trench that we dug.
This is one from
inside of the fort.
A couple of years ago we
did that from about 2009
to '12, around there.
So some really interesting
stuff going on.
Now, at the same rate, though,
the guy who has the quadcopter,
he also has a kite that he sends
up there with his camera on it,
and he's got a remote.
So there's all sorts
of ways, of course.
It can get really
windy here on the site.
There's not many
trees around, so it
can be really problematic.
But the quadcopter's
really a cool thing
that archaeologists
just generally
are using around various areas.
But I'm just going to
leave you with saying
that these things are
all really interesting
and they give us so much
information, but none of that
is ever going to find a
Vindolanda writing tablet.
So that's why I make this
real point that we really
do need to use
these new techniques
with our old proven ways.
Excavating, I don't think is
going to be actually getting
out there with your
trowel and your spade.
Never going to be
superseded I don't think.
Plus, it's a lot of fun.
You get to make mud
patties, wheelbarrows.
There's nothing better than
that fresh air all day.
So all of this is fantastic.
We get so much information,
and really it's
just growing exponentially all
the time with archaeology now.
But we still need
to get down there.
We need to get
dirty, and we need
to find more Vindolanda writing
tablets and similar things
like that.
So that is, I think, where
I'm going to leave you.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
When you were showing the--
ELIZABETH GREENE: Oh, do you
want the-- is it up here?
Oh, right.
AUDIENCE: When you were showing
the magneto scans earlier,
you said that sometimes you
will find stone stuff that
didn't show up on the scan.
ELIZABETH GREENE: Um-hmm.
AUDIENCE: Does the
other way happen too?
That some of you see
things on the scan
and there's nothing there?
ELIZABETH GREENE:
Well-- yeah, that's
a really, really good
question, because yes, indeed.
So like I said, we don't always
find the stone structures
that are there.
But that's also because
your ground soil matters.
It's very important what's
happening in the ground soil
because-- and also, then,
what technique you choose.
So what we're going
to do this summer,
we're still looking at
all of our possibilities.
But we probably won't
maybe use magnetometer.
We might use something
else just because it's
going to give you
different readings.
What happens is not so much
that there's nothing there,
but it's not quite
what you expected.
So you might get
a massive anomaly.
There is-- iron does
just sort of cluster.
It leaches and
clusters in the soil.
It could just be
naturally there.
And one time we did find
just this mass of-- you
can't get through it.
This massive clump
of iron that was just
a natural occurrence
in the soil.
Also, you'll notice-- see
all of these gray moving
along the edge here?
This is a road, right
here, the Stanegate.
That's a modern road,
and a modern field wall.
And all of those readings, you
get these really, really high
readings along the
edge, and that's simply
people throwing tin cans
and relieving themselves
over the wall for a good couple
of decades, modern road works
and things like that.
So often what it
is is that you find
something that you
didn't necessarily need
or a modern rubbish
heap of some sort.
An old wheelbarrow--
that happened.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Can you briefly speak
about some of the research
you've been doing on the shoes?
ELIZABETH GREENE: Oh, sure.
Absolutely.
So one of the things,
I said that those shoes
are very close to my heart.
That is something I
could have given you
an entire talk on shoes.
OK, so we have over
4,000 shoes, and they
are being used in all
sorts of interesting ways.
What I'm interested
in is looking
at who these shoes represent.
Because if you can believe
it, for decades and decades
and decades and
centuries, really, nobody
was really thinking about who
lived in these military forts,
in these military communities,
other than the soldiers.
It was a very sort of
misogynistic, very manly
environment, the Roman Army.
And we never talked about
the women who were there,
the children.
However, when these
Vindolanda shoes popped up,
a woman named Carol
van Driel-Murray back
in the early '90s,
she started looking
at certain contexts such
as barrack blocks, so
soldiers' barracks.
And realizing that there are
lots of children's and women's
shoes in these spaces.
People always wanted this to be
prostitutes and their children,
I guess.
And this is a real
problem with research.
This is not the way
the world works.
And so I started looking at
who these shoes represented.
Really cool stuff.
There's children's and women's
shoes all over the place.
And then one side is
bringing in other material
as well, such as the
documents that we mentioned--
the inscriptions,
other things like that,
realizing that women and
children and families,
in fact, are all over the
Roman military environment.
I'm also hoping this
summer, and this
is another one of
my collaborations,
I'm hoping this
summer to start doing
DNA analysis on a
lot of the leather.
And now you can't ask me any
more questions about that.
I'm still researching and
putting together my proposal.
Because it's actually
highly questionable
what we'll be able to get
out of Roman leather because
of the tanning process,
because of how long
they've been sitting
in the ground.
So I'm still
developing that plan,
but I'm hoping to be
able to understand
where the leather
was coming from.
So in other words, are
they importing that
from the continent?
Are they very, very local?
Is it coming from the South?
Kind of similar
questions of the ceramic.
I am also looking at-- I'm
working and collaborating
with a physical anthropologist
in Anthropology Department
at Durham University in
the UK, Dr. Trudi Buck.
And we're looking at things
like-- this is mostly
her department, to be
honest-- but looking
at things such as deformities
in the population.
So what are the
shoes showing us?
And in fact, when we look
closely at these shoes,
they are showing
us that the Romans
had a sense of individual gait.
They had a sense of
the fact that they
needed to fix things like
high arches and pronation
and supination.
So we have shoes
that have a metal
bar on either the inside or
the outer edge of a shoe.
Really cool stuff.
I could come back sometime and
talk an hour just about shoes.
So there's lots of really
interesting stuff going on.
Maybe after I do
this summer, it's
going to be really
interesting with testing,
if I can get
information out of this
and get the right
people on board.
Somebody asked me if we
could get any human DNA off
of the leather,
off of the shoes,
just because people
were wearing them.
I guess maybe through
sweat and things.
And you know, I don't know.
So I'm going to try to
find out things like this.
And if we can, wow, awesome.
That would be really cool.
Anyone have any input on that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It seems to me that
the idea that the women were
prostitutes would be
fantastically easy to initiate,
to get going.
You basically say it's troops.
Women were there, probably
prostitutes [INAUDIBLE].
ELIZABETH GREENE: Naturally.
AUDIENCE: But exceptionally
difficult to displace,
to get rid of that idea
once it's been established.
I used to have this tremendous
argument in art history
when I was in college, the
Venus of Willendorf figures.
I thought they were porn.
The professors all said they
were like fertility figures
or something like that.
Well, how do you know?
The difference between porn
and fertility [INAUDIBLE].
So in a situation like
this where everybody
has made the easy
lead to, oh, they
must have been prostitutes.
How do you go about the process
of showing and demonstrating
that they weren't prostitutes?
ELIZABETH GREENE: Yeah.
Really interesting.
Because one of things you're
bringing up is that surely,
there were prostitutes there.
That's the thing.
I mean almost every
human group, you
have certain things that happen.
You have women there.
When you women and men there,
you have children there.
And you also very
often have prostitutes.
And we know of prostitutes
throughout the Roman world,
throughout the Greek world,
throughout pretty much
any ancient society and modern.
So that's an absolute
fact of life.
So it's basically
what you're asking
is how do we pick apart
what sort of social class
or what type of people we're
talking about with these shoes.
Now, one thing we can do is look
at the archaeological context,
or also tied into that is
looking at the type of shoe.
One of the shoes that
I talk about a lot
is called the Lepidina slipper
because of where it's found.
It's found in the house
of the commanding officer.
It's a very high end shoe.
It has the maker's
mark throughout.
It's something
that we would like
to say probably a prostitute
wasn't able to afford
and wasn't able to buy.
But one of the points,
though, about saying, OK,
whether this is the shoe
of a prostitute or not,
that's very difficult to say.
You can point to
all these things,
this is very high end,
et cetera, et cetera.
It's very difficult to say
exactly who wore that shoe.
But the number now is so high
that all of those individuals
could not have been prostitutes.
The other thing, what I do,
coming from that cultural side
that I said with this
classic background,
I spent years and
years and years
reading ancient Greek and Latin.
I'm not going to forget it.
I'm going to use it.
Is that we can look
at the inscriptions,
we can look at the documents
that are left behind,
and we can see in
there that there
are families in
the Roman military.
So I bring in the
social aspect by looking
at something particularly called
the military diplomas, which
are these bronze documents,
their discharge documents.
And on those documents they
name the soldier at the bottom,
and if he chose, he named
his wife and his children,
and those children
got citizenship.
And that's a family right there.
That's not a prostitute.
Those are families right there.
And therefore, we also
know that those families
were in the military
environment.
They were in these communities
surrounding the army.
I should have given
my talk on this.
This is like my Ph.D. research.
Fantastic.
So we know that those
people are there.
And we just have to
then be able to-- we
can never in archaeology
say this shoe was
worn by this person.
That's not going to happen.
I suppose if they
signed their name on it.
AUDIENCE: Every time I
read "National Geographic"
or anything about
archeology, people are always
saying this was a prostitute,
this was a rich guy,
this was this
person [INAUDIBLE].
ELIZABETH GREENE: Yeah.
We make educated guesses from
the evidence that we have.
And oftentimes, there are
better and worse cases.
There are things where you're
saying, yup, absolutely.
That is definitely what looks
like is happening there.
But I like to bring in
all of the evidence.
So bring in the documents,
bring in the archaeology,
look at the context of the find,
look at the actual find itself.
there's a lot of
angles you can take
to be pretty sure
of what's happening.
Yes.
Another question.
AUDIENCE: So since
you brought it up,
do we know much about what's
happening-- so you're mentioned
about disability and injury.
If you're not a senator or
an equestrian or something
and you get injured as
far as the Roman military,
they have the
equivalent of the VA,
or [INAUDIBLE]
they're bigger now.
ELIZABETH GREENE: No.
We don't know of anything that
is, let's say, like the VA.
What we do have, we
have military hospitals
inside of a lot of these forts.
There are very large
ones, the legionary forts.
The fort you're looking
at here, Vindolanda,
is an auxiliary fort.
So that's actually a much
smaller non-citizen unit
that's living in this fort.
Anywhere between about
500 and 1,000 men.
Nominally, how many
are actually there.
It's around that.
You have cavalry units
that are attached to it,
so the number
changes a little bit.
Whereas a legion is technically
5,000 and all sorts of people
attached.
So we have much larger
hospitals in a legionary fort.
And there is also
evidence that soldiers
remained in the settlements that
were right next to the units,
right next to the military fort.
And to my mind, we don't
have any written document
that says this is
why I lived here.
But there are some soldiers
that appear to go home,
and we can kind of track their
movements through epigraphy,
through these inscriptions
and things they'd left behind.
And a lot of people that tend
to stay nearby, near the unit.
And to my mind it
seems like you're
staying near a familiarity,
in one respect.
But then also that
maybe you're still
utilizing those military
goods and services
that you had when
you were a soldier.
But we don't really have
anything written down
that says exactly what
happened or why they did this.
AUDIENCE: Those wives
you were talking about,
were their names Roman
or Celtic, usually?
ELIZABETH GREENE: Roman
for the most part.
So we don't really
have-- the soldiers,
though, this is a
really complicated--
do you guys have another hour?
We could go right
into something.
Those soldiers up in our
site and on almost all
of Hadrian's Wall are-- unless
you have vexilation unit.
We do have evidence that we do
have legionary soldiers there
at some point.
These are these
auxiliary units that
are being recruited from
the conquered provinces
of the Roman Empire.
And then often being shipped
outside of their home areas.
So the units we have are called
Tungrians for one, Batavians.
Tungrians are from
modern name Belgium.
Batavians are right around
the area of Amsterdam
in the Netherlands.
And so we have these
sort of culture units.
But then those became
multiculture units
in and of themselves
because then they
would be recruit
from areas local,
from areas that they were
traveling, from one place
to another.
So these became serious
multicultural groups.
So the names that we have, that
we know of, in our environment,
you do get ones
that are non-Roman,
but you also have people
that are taking Roman names,
because when they
get Roman citizenship
they're taking Roman names.
So it's a bit of mixture.
But you can never always tell.
Just a Roman name
doesn't always mean
that they weren't originally
from somewhere else.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.